[Musique]
oui
bonjour et bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale dave passe au toc tonnes
aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
des peuples autochtones qui est une
journée qui est consacrée à la culture
et aux traditions autochtones et pour
l'occasion nous allons
travailler aujourd'hui avec trois
journalistes autochtones que je vais
vous présenter immédiatement donc à ma
gauche c'est muriel rock comme une
énigme de malioténam cauet qui est
journaliste à la socam qui est la
société de communication attikameks
montagnaise qui est un réseau de radios
il ya aussi sous chan bacon qui est tito
aux nouvelles nationales de mtn qui est
le raisonne le réseau de télévision des
peuples autochtones et qui est aussi
innu de malioténam et ma collègue
gabriel paul despars autochtone qui est
une île nous de mashteuiatsh
et moi je suis à belmont petit je suis
aussi journaliste à l'espace autochtone
et je vais animer la démission
aujourd'hui nous avons la chance d'avoir
avec nous le ministre des relations
couronne autochtone et à faire du nord
canada qui est monsieur mark muller qui
a accepté de venir répondre à nos
questions aujourd'hui alors bienvenue
parmi nous monsieur le ministre
et nous sommes dans un endroit coin oui
nous sommes dans un très bel endroit
montréal on est au jardin botanique de
montréal qui est inquiétant un immense
jardin dans lequel il ya plusieurs
jardins thématiques où on peut voir des
plantes indigènes du québec et du canada
mais aussi des plantes ornementales et
ce qui est particulier c'est qu'il ya un
jardin des premières nations avec un
pavillon des premières nations qui a été
ouvert en 2001 et qui étaient dans les
projets de départ
quand le jardin botanique a été créée
dans les années 30 on voulait déjà créé
un jardin des premières-nations ça a été
fait beaucoup plus tard et dans ce
jardin on a des arbres indigènes du
canada on a des plantes sauvages aussi
qu'on peut observer et on a un pavillon
aussi où il ya des activités qui sont
ouvertes au public et où on peut voir de
l'artisanat autochtone entre autres et
c'est un endroit aussi le jardin des
premières nations où il ya des
cérémonies parfois autochtone qui se
déroule donc sait on c'est un endroit où
on est on est heureux d'être aujourd'hui
alors donc aujourd'hui on va aborder
différents thèmes d'actualité qui
touchent les personnes autochtones le
premier thème conte dont on va parler
c'est celui du territoire alors le
territoire c'est à la base de l'identité
autochtone et de toutes les questions
autochtones dont on entend parler
toujours un lien avec le territoire et
notre collègue gabriel est allé
rencontrer des gens du public pour leur
demander comment il voyait la relation
avec le territoire les autochtones et
non autochtones comment on pouvait
cohabitent et ou non ensemble alors on
va écouter ce que nous on nous ont dit
les gens la cohabitation puis le demi
des peuples autochtones
c'est important façon
il faut faut apprendre à cohabiter avec
le plus possible on attend à apprendre
oh oui moi c'est sûr va éventuellement
pour un temps parce que je suis j'ai eu
fini
j'ai
attaché à ma région du tout mais
certainement je pourrais vous retourner
la question posée à des autochtones est
ce qu'il serait prêt à collaborer avec
des noix qui entrerait au gouvernement
c'est la même c'est cela même le la même
forme de de tolérance et d'acceptation
de la différence qu on requiert de tout
le monde de quelque côté qu'on se trouve
qu'on n'a rien de cohabitation nos
enfants pourrait aussi éventuellement à
prendre je trouve que dg plus de multi
culturelle autour de nous mes enfants
vivent à l'école je trouve ça vraiment
pas deux autres autour de nuit aucun
enfant autochtone dans mon ouvrage ni à
l'école ni dans mon voisinage donc ce
serait ce pas vraiment
alors on faisait le territoire c'est la
base alors le territoire pour les
autochtones cela signifie de l'occuper
le territoire de l'occuper pleinement
mais aussi ça implique d'avoir des
discussions assez approfondies avec avec
entre les nations autochtones et les
différents niveaux de gouvernement et
sur jeanne avait une question pour
monsieur le ministre sur la question des
revendications territoriales
merci lithaire sont autochtones le
fédéral signent des ententes entre les
nations et les communautés autochtones
sans prendre en considération les
nations qui partagent le même territoire
comme ces hangars l'enjeu territoriale
en match de ryad et wendat quai ou si on
peut penser aussi à la convention de la
baie james où la communauté une marche
de et de maths mais coach l'argent et
touché directement
donc ma question est comment le fédéral
contre église torts qu'il a causés par
ce qu'il ya des hommes et des femmes et
des familles qui occupent le territoire
ce moment
[Musique]
et merci ce titre très
inquiétant non puis dans le contexte où
on en est vous avez vu parmi les peuples
allochtone non autochtone une prise de
conscience pour chivu peuple autochtone
relève de l'évidence même monde de
territoire on parle d'identité et dans
les règlements qu'on essaie de faire
c'est parfaitement compte fait il ya des
erreurs qui sont aussi peu importe que
ce soit un traité moderne ou où les
traités dans les territoires où je me
trouve aujourd'hui où il ya été où il ya
lieu de non respect des noirs ou blancs
qui a été créée et passons qu'on
installe l'importance de l'aspect dessus
à l'été puis du caractère sacré ces
traités mais dans un pays aussi vaste
que le non dit importante par le
territoire ça fait partie de notre
identité ça parle ça fait partie du coc
partage qu'il faut faire puis dans les
communautés
dans les communautés où il ya eu du
chevauchement par
documenté historiquement documenté et
encore des clivages et des clivages et
alimenté par par le colonialisme et en
fait quand on parle du vivre ensemble
donc c'est pas dit c'est pas facile
c'est toujours une question de s'asseoir
avec les gens en question de communiquer
d'abord des canaux des canaux des
chaînes de communication qui sont
toujours ouvertes et d'essayer de régler
des choses qui peuvent être oui très
épineuse très très émotionnel en fin de
compte mais ce qu'on réalise c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup de bonne foi à l'intérieur
des des nations il ya un esprit de
vouloir émigrer régler le tout de façon
pacifique
monsieur le ministre ben vous mentionnez
vouloir régler de manière pacifique
les questions territoriales votre
gouvernement est engagé dans plusieurs
négociations territoriales avec des
premières nations à travers le pays
est-ce que vous avez un plan de match
pour compléter ces négociations
[Musique]
oui puis malheureusement force est de
constater que il ya beaucoup de ces
négociations beaucoup de ces clivages
qui vont qui vont perdurer par
le gouvernement mais après le
gouvernement
libéral il ya des réalités
il ya des conflits qui ré qui remonte
bien de la création du canada on sait
très bien au québec
mais un plan de match par match c'est de
régler cette façon oui pacifique nord ou
en dehors d'un contexte qui qui qui
quitte très peu propices à l'arrêt
consiste réconciliation c'est à
l'intérieur du court parce qu'on essaie
de faire au sein de mon ministère et au
sein d'autres ministères qui sont
concernés et touchés par les enjeux
notre rôle c'est de s'engager avec nous
à vos codes s'assurer que les arguments
sont faits sont façon respectueuse
qui font qu'ils reflètent l'esprit
vouloir il l'esprit de conciliation à
l'extérieur d'une cour ça peut être des
discussions qui sont de très longue
haleine il ya beaucoup de percer dans
les dernières années mais si on regarde
tout le temps tu est décrit dans les
derniers dans les derniers siècles il
reste beaucoup de travail à faire c'est
un travail que je fais directement avec
le ministre l'a métier pour pour
s'assurer les gens
les gens savent qu'on est un
gouvernement qui équivaut à pâte à la
table de négociation et non en cours
évidemment un forum qui ne se prennent
s'apprête terriblement à la
réconciliation pense que c'est un
contexte cette contexte très binaire de
peu confus il reste encore qui est des
conflits qui qui demeure en cours ou
mais là la question est vraiment réduire
les arguments au strict minimum de ce
qui ce qui doit être jugé par par une
séance passée merci ce ministre on va on
voit passer maintenant au deuxième thème
qui est celui de l'eau potable
on sait qu encore aujourd'hui de
nombreuses communautés autochtones qui
n'ont pas accès à l'eau potable
gabriel est allé discuter avec nos
concitoyens de cette question-là de
manque d'eau potable chez les
autochtones on va les écouter
communauté encore aujourd'hui qui ont
pas accès à l'eau potable est ce que
vous trouvez ça normal au canada dans un
des pays les plus riches de la planète
qu'il y ait ces problèmes là où se
négligent
à quelque part c'est comme si en 2002
2022 on devra être de l'eau potable
partout c'est la pleine autorité mais
québec au canada surtout canadienne de
doha masse je peux pas croire qu'il ya
encore des endroits où ils n'ont pas
d'eau potable
et déjà restait une place moi qui étais
presque en ville que j'avais un puits
sec je peux pas croire que sont pour
être en avoir je vais pas imaginer qu
ailleurs il ya même pas d'où il ya même
pas de raison comment vu comment voulons
nous que ces gens l'ont éventuellement
se joindre rejoindre une communauté ici
sont complètement isolés par ce genre de
chose le souhait parle ou par les
réseaux ou quoi que ce soit comme dans
ce type de jeu que je comprends pas
qu'en 2025 soit encore possible
injustement donc depuis 2015 on sait
qu'il ya quand même des dizaines de
communautés qui ont récupéré l'accès à
l'eau potable qu'ils n'ont plus à faire
bouillir l'eau pour la boire ou pour
s'en servir pour prendre leur douche
pour se laver ou faire la cuisine mais
il reste quand même encore 29
communautés qui doivent faire bouillir
l'eau et il ya même une communauté qui
qui est sans eau potable depuis on a vu
cette semaine que ça faisait déjà dit
mille jours donc plus de 27 ans que
cette communauté étaient sans eau
potable alors muriel quelques questions
pour un monsieur le ministre sur cette
question là alors le gouvernement est
rude ou a promis en deux pièces de l'eau
potable pour sa collectivité des
premières nations
la date limite pour sa promesse était
prévue en mars 2010 2015 en mars 2021
pardon et le gouvernement fédéral n'a
pas encore de plan pour l'accès à l'eau
potable chez les premières nations vous
en êtes où avec ses dossiers
merci muriel et de un
fake ou avec mes concitoyens c'est
inacceptable la réalité c'est que dans
un pays aussi vaste que note avec des
ressources en eau en eau potable aucune
communauté ne devrait priver d'eau que
d'eau potable fraîche
l'arrêter au dans laquelle on a fait
face on rentre au gouvernement s'il y
avait des
centaines d'avis à long terme qui
cataloguent parfois depuis des décennies
notre gouvernement s'est affairé à faire
des investissements records des
milliards dhs alors un investissement
capital pour beaucoup au palier à ce
qui vraiment
tellement inacceptable que ces
données des excuses franchement
de là à travers des communautés pour
lever ces avis ça a été tout un travail
depuis les cinq dernières années à un
dernier constat y en avait 134 david
évolution à long terme de lever il reste
au delà vous l'avez constaté vous même
au delà d'une demi-douzaine de deux
douzaines plutôt deux communautés qui
ont des avis à lever important de savoir
que c'est pas le gouvernement du canada
tient aux la levée des avis à long terme
céder communauté elle-même dans le dal
claude communauté qui restent il y avoue
dossier épineux qui qui qui n'a que ces
communautés mais reste que le
gouvernement et est là avec un plan
chaque communauté a un plan pour relever
cet avis et avis à long terme il ya
beaucoup de communautés qui avec cause
ont refusé les solutions à moyen et à
court terme qu'on aura affaire il ya
toujours une méfiance dans les
communautés fermement avec cause pour
vous vis-à-vis du gouvernement du canada
qui vante acteurs gros sabots avec un
nouveau plan mais là dans le contexte
d'un actif donc comme une nouvelle usine
en eau potable
c'est un non sens que ça n'existe pas et
que les communautés n'ont pas accès à
nos frais haché potable
depuis la dernière mais mises à part en
dépit du cld a crevé dans ma pub avec
les communautés de lever un peu près
votre avis il reste que oui en cours de
route il ya des constats qui se sont
faits oui on a un tel investissement
capital à la ferme investissements dans
la commune autistes c'est-à-dire
d'investir les opérateurs pour s'assurer
que cet actif qui la fierté d'une
communauté plus cette puce est
entretenue qui est des investissements
plus
plus élargie dans les communautés c'est
à dire de raccrocher les maisons il ya
beaucoup de communautés qui qui qui peut
appartition une valise et moutarde à
lever leur avis parce qu'ils ont besoin
d'autres investissements qui sont
critiques à la communauté suisse est un
processus qu'il faut respecter mon
comptable de partenariat on parle
d'investissements accrus dans les
communautés je pense qu'on en arrive
j'ai confiance dans la nouvelle ministre
qui est responsable de ça j'avais cette
responsabilité avant avant que je prenne
le 10ème position mais paris a dù
travaille avec les communautés surtout
dans la cadre de la couronne du nord de
l'ontario où le problème est à son plus
grave encore il faut respecter la prise
de décision dans les communautés et
parfois le temps que ça prend pour lever
ces avis dans les 29 communautés qui
reste il ya de l'eau fraîche dans
plusieurs de ces communautés mais la vie
tarder à être levés ça c'est un
processus avec lequel il faut respecter
la prise de décision à l'intérieur comme
une tenait alors les gens essaient de
comprendre ce qui se passe parce que
c'est un dossier qui revient constamment
il ya des gens qui disent est ce que
c'est le manque de matériaux le manque
de ressources ou ne manque de temps que
ce qui fait qu est-ce qui fait
exactement qui les gens peut pas régler
ce dossier une fois pour toutes
dans le club évidemment sans doute d'une
épidémie une pandémie globale qui qui
qui a causé oui des délais durant les
deux dernières années son excuse d'un
fait dans le cas d'une communauté où il
ya eu deux décennies l dopa 2 de manque
d'eau potable c'est pas quelque chose
qui peut se justifier nécessairement
mais c'est la réalité avec laquelle on
compose à l'investissement en capital
afic tard le général l'a dit lui-même
malmène les investissements capitale
sont là les investissements maintenance
puis en opération des dés de ses actifs
qui sont la fierté de la communauté
manquer on à combler ce trou et là il
reste encore des investissements pour
s'assurer puis communaux qui puisse
avoir des solutions élargie qui
entourent
l'acheminement en eau potable qui à
strictement parler
non pas nécessairement à avoir avec la
levée de la vie mais qui sont critiques
à la communauté quelle communauté
voudraient lever son avis d'eau potable
à long terme qui acheminaient à une
école par exemple des us vieille de 50
ans qui voulait remplacer à tout coup
alors je comprend plus de parfois la
prise de décision qui requiert plus
d'investissements qui ne sont pas
naturellement nécessairement connecter à
cet avis mais qui sont critiques à la
vie puis à la vitalité de la communauté
merci donc on va passer au troisième
thème qui est celui de la violence
envers les femmes autochtones qui est
aussi un terme très lourd encore
aujourd'hui les femmes autochtones sont
plus susceptibles de subir de la
violence ou d'être assassinés ou de
disparaître que la moyenne des femmes
canadiennes
gabriel en a parlé avec des gens du
public on veut les écouter
sont plus victimes de violence que
d'autres femmes au pays qu'est ce que ça
vous fait quand vous entendez ce puis
qu'est ce qui devrait être fait selon
vous
malheureusement je le sais pas qu'est ce
qui pourrait être fait c'est sûr qu'ils
devraient avoir des
des actions prises console mais oui je
sais je l'entends comme tout le monde
l'a oublié je trouve ça très dommage une
situation qui est absolument terrible
parce qu on est encore dans le racisme à
100 on est tous égaux on est tous une
même famille ces aides ont nous aimons
nous
c'est ce que je vois à 10 ça me désole
fin désole que je peux pas croire que ça
perdure encore ont partagé pas mal les
mêmes types de violence pour des raisons
de discriminations de toutes sortes oui
avec celle avec ceci de différent j'ai
dit que on n'a rien fait pour améliorer
leur sort même sur leur territoire par
les autorités ou la politique otunnu je
ne trouve pas qu'on est appuyé donc pour
comme ma femme caucasienne je trouve ça
difficile où suppriment pas imaginer ce
que ça doit et de vivre comme
autochtones avec leur passé leur
histoire fatal
bon justement donc pour faire face à ce
problème de violence qui touche
particulièrement les femmes autochtones
ya une commission d' enquête qui avait
été nommé qui a rendu son rapport il ya
déjà trois ans et dans ce rapport il y
avait deux cent trente et une
recommandation il y en a quelques-unes
qui ont été mises en vigueur mais en
reste un grand nombre gabriel avait une
question pour monsieur le ministre mais
l'air à ce sujet oui monsieur mais leur
votre gouvernement produit l'an dernier
un plan d'action justement pour répondre
aux recommandations de l'enquêté
nationale sur les femmes autochtones
disparues et assassinées
mais visiblement c'est un problème
qui ne serait que la peau qui est
difficile à régler parce que seulement
au cours du mois de mai trois femmes
autochtones ont été assassinés à
winnipeg est-ce qu'à ottawa vous sentez
l'urgence d'agir
absolument puis
force est de constater que c'est une
tragédie qui continue
et
surtout avec la pandémie qui tire à sa
fin on a vu une augmentation en fait la
violence conjugale
puis l'impact qui s'est fait ressentir
dans les communautés autochtones et
surtout ceux et celles qui sont les plus
vulnérables c'est-à-dire et jeunes
hommes les femmes et les filles
autochtones et les populations lgbt q ce
que le rapport de leurs fans nous est
dit très clairement c'est qu'il fallait
une réponse non seulement du
gouvernement fédéral de tous les
gouvernements mais une réponse de
société un problème qui était systémique
ce problème systémique repose sur
plusieurs bases accès et dénis de la
justice accède et ni de l'assurance en
sécurité physique c'est à dire auprès
des forces policières qu'il faut qui qui
qui qui qui qui sont
et qui sont encore en cause en ce qui a
trait aux grasses et systémique on a vu
très clairement dans les dernières
années un investissement en capital
infrastructures pour accueillir ces
femmes pour pour en sorte traiter les
symptômes qui sont très très très très
très violent
la réalité dans tout ça c'est que
personne ne devrait rester sur ses
lauriers peu importe notre réponse à la
al assad à peu importe les
investissements depuis en milliards de
dollars dans plusieurs organes à l'égard
des organisations qui traite de façon
quotidienne avec les avec les femmes qui
maintenant du financement pour les
accueillir
le problème est toujours là et puis
personne doit être satisfait tant et
aussi longtemps que nous sommes les
enfants autochtones ne sont pas en
sécurité dans ce pays
d'ici le dire que rien n'a été fait je
pense que les résultats tardent à suivre
au cours des dernières années plusieurs
investissements dans les gîtes dans
l'infrastructure ça serait qu'à plus
plus d'hébergement pour les femmes et
les enfants en danger
la nouvelle loi qui vient de passer dans
la chambre des communes ces cinq sont
des peines minimales un traître à des
femmes qui sont dans le milieu carcéral
les investissements dans les événements
et la rectification de la violence qui
fait en faire des enfants et automne
dans le système de garde qui toujours
encore brisé ça va des game schengen en
bon français pourrait surtout pour les
gens qui sont touchés directement par le
rapport de la fadeur il reste encore que
vu que la tragédie se poursuit vous revu
qu'elle ait des résultats tardent à
suivre comme difficile de dire haut et
fort qu'on fait du super bon travail
mais s'il ya vraiment une leçon à tirer
même en dépit face à des tragédies ce
qui ce qui se répète c'est qu'il faut
continuer garder le cap dans les
investissements pour les femmes et les
filles autochtones les personnes lgbt
qui menace et que ça soit c'est un
problème qui touche des provinces les
territoires et aussi que ça soit dans
les communautés autochtones elle même
aussi dans le milieu urbain etc pour
c'est pour ça mais en fait d'aller
encore sliimy que les clics les
communautés le visiteur du territoire
des provinces sont touchées directement
la limite effective la juridiction
fédérale
fait en sorte que difficile d'agir
directement dans un milieu urbain mais
c'est là où tout ça se fait ressentir
vous avez nommé les personnes qui ont
une école qui ont récemment été
découvert entre autres à winnipeg a une
importance d'engager la province du
manitoba au québec d'engager la province
du québec ou sept ans je n'ai pas
forcément en haut de l'échiquier
politique
il reste que les alertant les
buffalos ça existe encore ça devrait
être éliminé la stérilisation forcée
persiste et signe dans un pays comme le
nom c'est un enjeu d'abord et avant tout
dont il faut parler dans ce traité de
façon de façon sensible et au public
prévoit comme nouvelles mesures pour la
sécurité des femmes
ce n'est celle en question et pull et
le budget de 2021 entre autres
prévoyaient
prévoyez plusieurs choses dont 2
milliards en investissements ciblés
ciblées en réponse à notre projet
fédéral pour répondre à l'enfer mais
aussi pour s'assurer que les femmes
soient protégés déploiement d'argent
durant les prochaines années pour
s'assurer que les femmes sont en
détresse puisards puisse avoir des gîtes
de l'hébergement et puis 7 bien
accueilli on parle d'une cinquantaine de
cheveux j'étais d'hébergement ciblé hors
réserve languit mais là qui vont être
déployés à travers nos investissements
une lutte entre
deux stratégies anti violence qui qui
couvait évidemment les femmes et les
filles autochtones mais aussi l'ensemble
la population donc ce sont des choses
auxquelles il va falloir surveiller de
très près pour s'assurer que les
investissements touche le terrain mais
c'est prévu dans le dernier budget puis
on tendra pas agir davantage si jamais
on a besoin d'investissements et puis
j'ose croire qu'ils vont avoir besoin
évidemment
vous parlez je voudrais que nos
journalistes se présente un peu plus que
ce qu'on a ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à
maintenant muriel vous travaillez à la
socam donc la société de communication
attikameks montagne et vous vous nous
parler de votre travail
de cette radio qui est bien particulière
le travail qu'on fait
ça port
du réseau local situé 1 wang hockey et
on veut rejoindre les communautés
autochtones hinault attikameks que nous
c'est comme dans d'autres à dulce
beaucoup l'actualité c'est beaucoup
aussi aller sur ces maisons qui font
qu'ils font avancer des dossiers dans
nos communautés qui font que ça peut
nous aider à nous et pas nourrir nous
réaliser j'ai beaucoup là-dedans qu'on
est aussi dans nos entrevues et vous
diffuser en innu ans nino ce qui est
important parce que ces radios l'ont le
réseau a été mis en la commission de la
langue la sauvegarde et la promotion de
la langue je vous ai partagé sa jeunesse
avant
d'aller en ondes que lorsque moi j'ai
commencé c'était important pour moi de
vraiment travailler ma propre langue de
l'approfondir
je voyais pas comment je pouvais faire
de la radio est mêlé les langues la
langue inoue le français pour moi ce qui
était important c'était et nous
mais les mélanger les deux langues j'ai
sûrement un bon modèle aussi pour vos
auditeurs de quelqu'un qui utilise sa
langue à 100% oui oui les sous-sols vous
vous êtes au réseau de télévision des
peuples autochtones vous animé
l'émission
actualité nationale pouvez vous nous en
parler du réseau et de votre émission
oui moi j'allume le réseau l'émission
qui était demandeur de nouvelles
nationales d'apn le long une soir à
18h30 sur le réseau puis on aborde le
sujet des enjeux
autochtones l'actualité autochtone
francophones au québec puis on est la
partie de nouvelles nationales d'appétit
et la partie francophone de nouvelles
d'ap etienne parce que l'équipe a pété
un chameau news puis depuis 2009
capitaine a créé cette émission
d'actualité autochtones francophones au
québec donc oui je suis vraiment honoré
une sida ni mu s'était mission nouvelle
parce que c'est important d'entendre les
voix des communautés autochtones au
québec de savoir ce qui se passe dans
chaque communauté les onze nations on a
fait d'être partout on a quand même
hebdomadaire temps nos 24 mines de
nouvelle où est on sélectionne vraiment
pour faire des soins de schirrhein
plus gabriel paul voulez vous nous
parler brièvement de ce pass autochtone
aussi certainement pas un espace auto
tune qui est un site web de radio-canada
dans lequel on traite les actualités qui
touche les autochtones à travers le pays
qui ont produit également des reportages
sur le terre et on va rencontrer les
gens puissants je pense que c'est
vraiment important dans le métier qu'on
fait puis pour moi c'est vraiment un
plaisir et un privilège d'être à
distance autochtone malgré le fait que
je sois une jeune journaliste parce que
ça me permet vraiment de faire entendre
les voix des gens qu'on entend peu puis
de partager des histoires méconnues
aussi fini qui permet de nous mettre de
la voir nous les sonotones chez nous
comme blanc scène c'est important aussi
de travailler avec des autochtones parce
qu'on ne nous offre une perspective
qu'on n'a pas exactement il se doit cet
automne c'est merveilleux pour ce parce
que je me vois vraiment comme un lieu de
rencontres et des changes il ya des
collègues autochtone et des collègues
non autochtone puis on ça nous permet de
partager nos différentes connaissances
donc c'est vraiment assurément riche
merci on va revenir avec monsieur le
ministre à müller pour le dernier thème
de l'émission qui est un thème aussi qui
est pas facile qui est celui du racisme
systémique qui est un thème qui suscite
beaucoup de débats au québec et
d'ailleurs au canada
gabriel a posé des questions à nos à nos
concitoyens sur ce sujet là aussi qu'on
va écouter
le racisme systémique on a beaucoup
entendu parler dans la dernière année le
gouvernement du québec dit que ça
existait pas le gouvernement du canada
oui vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
existe ça existe on le voit
on a juste à se promener ici à montréal
puis on le voit tout de suite là quand
des gens qui sont à côté de notre
culture
il se tasse ou il leur parle paul leur
disent pas bonjour en marche un jeu ça
existe aussi tout quelqu'un passe un
commentaire salut ni l'interessé
systémique tout ce qui entoure ce terme
là devrait être très mieux définis et
pour moi il est soit complètement
complètement clair donc je m'exprimerai
avec beaucoup de nuances sur le sujet
l'un sur le racisme systémique exister
on était moins pas au quotidien mais a
su qu'il existait le nier je pense que
ses
mains c'est quasiment des dix
respectueux envers les irrespectueux
envers ses pairs les personnes qui en
sont victimes sur le terrain les gens
qui le vit je pense que vous pourrez les
écouter parce que j'ai l'impression que
unis il est temps qu'il le voie
systémique gèle ses poches personnes
pour 10 c'est sûr ça existe mais je
ressens que oui
alors donc depuis dure un an ou deux on
entends je pense que le grand public est
de plus en plus sensibilisés au fait que
les autochtones ont connu des
souffrances sont connus du mauvais
traitements mais
le racisme est toujours présent et sous
chan avait des questions à poser à
monsieur miller à ce sujet au fédéral il
ya des employés autochtone dans vont se
trouve dans votre dans vos organismes
gouvernementaux tout fédéral puis ils
vivent de la discrimination il visera 6
des préjugés
ils font des plaintes les plans de son
port retenu puis ce qui s'affaisse et
qui quittent leur emploi donc o'shea
vous comment comptez vous régler sera si
ce système éclats de ses employés riche
culturellement piquion cette
petit roman là qui les définissent
aussi une excellente question parce
qu'on a eu l'habitude de parler
de parler de déni sur la cécité mais
qu'au québec mais ce que j'essaie de
souligner c'est comme à boni ça veut pas
dire que tu vas voir disparaître
n'existe pas pour
les actions fédérales
ont beaucoup de raciste systémique à
l'intérieur de leurs erreurs du passé et
j'ai beau dire moi même que dans une
démocratie pluraliste
moi je ne peux pas décider comme uniski
qui je peux quand je dis que tu peux
garder
cette indépendance est très importante
le bon fonctionnement de notre
démocratie
il risque au sein de systèmes de mon
propre ministère de l'ami du ministère
de de paris à edou et honduras est
systémique et les autochtones en suisse
les séquelles
il ya beaucoup de travail qui était fixé
ces sites en dinosaure dernières années
pour rectifier ce problème j'ai beaucoup
confiance dans le national dans la donne
dur classique pour régler
régler ce problème que les gens vivent
au quotidien il ya beaucoup de
ministères qui qui ont très peu de
tonnes très peu de gens de racialiser
cela en soi c'est en effet du raincy
systémique pilotes qui sont là ils
subissent des préjugés et parfois des
dans les consciences alors
l'obstacle qui nous avions passé en
entrevue est correct qu'il faut avoir
une certaine nuance à 7 à ce problème
ont parfois de 2 à 6 le raciste on peut
confronter directement
à foyer là mais quand on parle de
ressusciter mais qu'on parle
d'expérience des gens du vécu des gens
dans le quotidien et c'est quelque chose
pour être plus difficile à éradiquer
mais qu'il faut confronter absolument
on
ne peut pas en venir à des situations où
il ya des recours collectifs c'est
parfois le résultat mais faut l'adresser
parce qu'on parle du droit d'une
personne de vivre et travailler en paix
sans être jugés 500 être jugé sans être
assujetti aux vins systémique dans le
quotidien dans le travail ou de gagner
enfin encore moins dans les situations
où les gens où ils en sécurité physique
sont en son temps question c'est à dire
face aux forces de l'ordre
face à aux systèmes de santé une
personne comme moi n'ayons jamais eue
craint d'aller dans un hôpital c'est pas
le vécu d'une personne payton d'un bout
de très peu de tekken qui appréhendent
est qui qui parfois refuse de se
présenter dans un système
de santé hospitaliers qui se pose est
l'arrêt des l'inversé arrive donc ça
prend une société faut confronter encore
là faut d'abord ne pas avoir peur du mot
puis les conséquences à seuls les
employés qui quittent les ses employés
au total un kit vous vous êtes un
gouvernementaux mais ça crée un
phénomène que tous connaissent
maintenant les employés les employés
autour déclaré autochtone oui qu ils
cochent sous le forme l'arc sont autant
depuis que personne n'a vérifié si ces
personnes-là ses employés leur
réussissent dans un environnement bur
bureaucratique puis vous l'a tant que
représentant du gouvernement m'attend
comment comptez-vous contrer ce
phénomène là aussi
vous parler de gens qui se tordent
déclaré et
il ya passé en provence facile si on est
dans une personne comme moi dhabi
de prime abord ce jeu j'ai pas le droit
de dicter qui d'embauché qui n'est pas
embauché on sait très bien que les gays
il ya certains gens qui pensent
peut-être avoir un avantage en se
déclarant autochtone en même temps
s'imposer comme le contrôleur ou la
personne qui juge ayant
la discussion finale sur qui et qui
n'est pas tous comme ça fait partie de
l'histoire du canada alors on est dans
une commune gouvernement une position
très difficile le deet est qui et qui
n'est pas encore tonnes on se fie à la
bonne foi des gens j'oserais dire sans
avoir des preuves à l'appui que la vaste
majorité des des autochtones qui
travaillent au sein de la fonction
publique sont en fait des tonnes faut
bien croire des gens sur leur bonne foi
mais dans tout contexte des pionniers de
nous comme journalistes ayant couvert
ces enjeux vous l'avez constaté vous
même il ya des gens qui qui essaie de
jouer avec le système pas de solution
facile à tout ça c'est un produit tout
ça c'est un enjeu croissant au sein de
la société
mais c'est quelque chose dont on n'est
pas aveugle à l'existence
de concertations entre le québec et le
canada pour enrayer le raciste
[Musique]
j
pas une façon formelle disons qu'ils
fonctionnent à sa juste valeur j'ai
toujours cru en la bonne foi des
ministres lesquels je travaille
évidemment au plan politique qui a vu se
dénude assez systémique alors on est en
désaccord assez formelle en ce qui a
trait son existence même alors difficile
de pallier aux problèmes qu'ils endurent
pis ou tant que sont les effets et les
conséquences de ce déni
encore une fois le problème ne
disparaîtra pas simplement en le liant
il ya quand même des mesures pour
attaquer le racisme il ya quand même des
mesures que nous avons mis en place
beaucoup pour combattre le racisme
raciste systémique avec de l'argent à
l'appui au niveau fédéral réforme du
système le rôle du fédéral dans la
réforme du système de santé surtout visé
sur la sensibilité culturelle auprès des
autochtones mais reste encore et
évidemment dans l'ia un rôle on se
questionne parfois le rôle du fédéral
dans ce rôle moral évidemment mais rôle
direct sont reformés la commission vient
il ya beaucoup d'investissements qui
relève directement du fédéral qu'on
pourrait palier qui alimente ce cette
forme de raciste systémique
mais il ya du travail évidemment dans le
bal jeudi son effectif des gouvernements
à travers à travers le canada un taquet
ce problème dans le système de soins de
santé on parle entre autres du principe
de joyce dont parle d'équité en mai
allochtone et les autochtones mais céder
10,6 du travail qui de longue haleine
qui va qui va qui va perdurer il ya
beaucoup de pistes de solution que ça
soit ou à l'intérieur du québec dans le
grand nord ou en colombie britannique
pour attaquer ce problème mais ça
problème perdure qui persistent et qui
sait
sortir à sa fin je vous remercie
beaucoup monsieur millar d'avoir répondu
aux questions des journalistes avec avec
sincérité on sent dans votre vous
admettez des choses que les politiciens
admettent pas habituellement j'avoue que
c'est c'est rafraîchissant de vous
entendre on constate aussi que les
problèmes sont loin d'être réglés on
sent une volonté mais ça demande
énormément de travail encore donc on
espère qu'on aura des bonnes nouvelles
qu'on pour annoncer à la population
c'est la fin de votre mandat alors merci
beaucoup encore une fois beaucoup
j'ajouterai ce que je voudrais
simplement il ya beaucoup d'entrées je
fous le garder mais je dois finalement
parce qu'ils sont une question le 21 de
souligner les bonnes choses qui se
passent dans le pays ifs et votre
travail très important nationale vous
avez su avec vos interlocuteurs qui a un
besoin de savoir j'ai mes enfants mes
enfants apprennent plus que j'en
apprenais dans le temps mais le travail
que vous faites est indispensable je
tenais absolument le suivant quitter
merci je veux remercier aussi nos
invités
nos journalistes qui ont posé de bonnes
questions
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de ce pass autochtone et
puis j'espère qu'on pourra reprendre une
collaboration ensemble parce que c'est
ça apporte énormément je trouve moi je
suis allochtone ça rapporte beaucoup
d'avoir ce point de vue qui est le vôtre
que vous seul pouvez transférer jusqu'à
maintenant les années n'a souhaité ni
sait jamais rien mais non
merci à tout le monde aussi
[Musique]